this is a production of Cornell
University
while tomato species you seen you know
me didn't technology be a crisper cast
night so as we know the current
agricultural status and the war is that
right now we are eight billion people
around the world is expected for 2050
we're going to be at almost 10 billion
people and we really required that we
increment or arable lands for 20% to
feed all this amount of people but as
breather so we know that the
productivity in agriculture is not only
defined by the ARB the availability of
arable lands but also by the different
effects of different factors like
climate change effects and environmental
deterioration there can be composed by
biotic and abiotic factors in the case
of biotic factors we are dealing with
the salinization that is a really big
problem around the world who is affect
which is affecting hardly the gill of
the crops and it is expected or it is
estimated that 20 percent of irrigated
land around the world is compromised by
this problem and every year we're losing
10 my millions of hectares of this land
compromised by this concern and it is
also expected that for 2050 half of the
arable lands around the world will be
affected by so the initiation in these
pictures I just want to show you
I are even extreme levels of sonic
salinization so tomato why tomato was us
we know tomatoes a really important
group around the war with a annual
production of 15 million million of
metric tones and use in United States
and the market value for this crop is
around 2.6 billion the final firming
gate value in this case reporting in
2015 but as we know tomato is not only
used for food and the results are great
moral force to the genetics evolutionary
biology but they can have buttock
stresses responses and thanks to the
creation of the tomato genome concern in
2012 and the 100 tomato genome
sequencing culture in 2014 a lot of
research has been done on this in this
regard but tomato as many other crops
around the world has suffered of this of
the domestication sign syndrome which
decreased the genetic diversity of this
plan and also the nutritional values the
resistance of these plants and the fruit
setting as a result we increase their
fruit size and the gill and in different
ways by conventional breathing
procedures in space I just want to show
you for example the wild ancestor of the
tomato the Solon pimple and you volume
by single mutations in these two genes
these are both to the solanum
lycopersicum that we now use for the
Kuti very tomato and the clear example
of the change on the fruit so for
conventional breathing the use of wild
pitches has been exploited a lot due to
looking for increasing the genetic
diversity of the crop and also looking
for tools to increase the by taking
about a stress response of the cultivars
here I'm going to show you that
according to the tomato clade we have
around 17 17 species in table we can see
the Salonika person that is a cutie very
one and many variation or genetic
diversity has been found in other well
spacious in order to increase some
traits on the
this cultivar however this is not always
the case when we are talking about
polygenic tricks like drug resistance or
salinity resistant core resistance so in
this case this this experiment published
in 2017 for a proposal by Benetton Paris
they show they perform experiment using
a gradient of salt in this case from
fifty to four hundred sixty million
Buhler of sodium chloride and you can
see that they are start using this
accession of Salonga epigenesis
accession la 1401 compared to the
cultivar the Salonika
sun only copper zircon m82 and when they
created an increase until 460 millimolar
sodium chloride only the accession from
the salon Gallipolis is why it was able
to survive on these conditions while the
cultivar is clearly here dead also
thanks to a different approach or
differenced study published in 2017
bobtails she shows or she was trying to
discern water what were the mechanisms
involved in the salinity resistance
insulin she's money that is also our
closer relative to Seoul and Galapagos
and she shows that there were two main
mechanisms involved in this pro in this
process starting with exclusion on the
roots and also a compartmentalization of
the sodium on the older leaves to keep a
low level of potassium
she shows that the best-performing
accession of these species was the so
languages money accession
0 for 21 so for the purposes of my
research i'm using this accusation i
just want to show you here what is the
phenotypic or the morphological
characteristics of this plant who is
originally from the Galapagos Island and
it grows close to the seashore like you
can see in this picture it's an agonist
and self compatible plant and the fruit
that produces that really is a great
tomato a yellowish tomato in
the case this is the picture of my
fruits in the greenhouse they look
orange wish so the main goal of my
projects to develop a de novo
domestication approach that was
introduced by someone in 2017 that
states that instead of trying to
introduce their alleles to improve a
complex trait like a polygenic trait
into in tall or quote verse the idea is
to introduce they already known
domesticated alleles into the wall
species to harbor their already
occurring resistance to polygenic o to
complex traits like salinity or drought
or coal resistance so to achieve this
goal I'm using CRISPR cast night
technology because as you know it's a
shape that's simple and precise a
technology and also it allows you to to
do a multiplex fashion knockout of the
genes that you want to knock out well
these are the EGA genes that I'm using
to knock out to generate single mutants
in tomato and these are the phenotypes
that would be affected by this loss of
solution alleles so these are the goals
of my project by generating these
knockouts in these genes were going to
influence the cone we're going to try to
achieve a compact or instructor butter
flour in Physiology a hydrogel and a
more nutritious fruit these are the two
principal approaches that I'm taking I'm
generating this single mutants plans for
this tomato and also doing a parallel
approach to knock out these five genes
at the same time to generate or to
affect these five phenotypes on the
plant by using transformation by
aggravating tumefaciens we are reducing
the cells for from cotyledons here i
just want to show you the explains to
promote the should development there we
promote the root development then we
transfer them to soil conditions and we
a climatic plans before transfer them to
the greenhouse facilities in this case
I'm just showing you two
the mutant lines that we already have
they're growing until now these are my
preliminary results we we're having or
we were performing a lot of
transformations or all the genes the
single new cows and also we're still
going with the multiplex knockout so the
next steps is to keep going with agar
bacterium tumefaciens information on the
tomato and the cotyledons tissue and
then wait for during the proper
regeneration of the plants and then
confirm these mutations by PCR and I
think I go I went a little bit well I
just want to acknowledge my team them my
colleagues aware there there was near
helping me a lot with experiments and of
course my advice for the dr. Buckner
very neat
regna leader from the Department of soil
science plannin solo science from West
Virginia University and the dr. Laura
Paris who is working with us in
collaboration from Brazil and of course
the Sao Paolo Research Foundation who is
helping me to do my Master's here in the
United States and their respective
institutions of my colleague school
where they're working with me along this
work thank you I'm glad to hear your
questions there are something that you
want to ask you checked it Thank You
Chad yeah thank you
if have questions please feel free to
either to write those in the chat or to
raise your hand and ask them directly is
there any question it looks like there's
one in the chat right now from Jarrett
man and then another one from Anna
Herman's I can see now I can see the
shed will you kill me a reading there
questions please Sarah first Jarrett
would you like to read your question
yeah sure um so that was great thank you
um I know that the
the solanum family does tend to produce
compounds that are not desirable in our
crops and I was wondering if there was
any idea if there if I don't know
cheese money I don't know if they they
make anything that we would like to get
rid of but if this technique could be
used for that yeah actually one of the
reasons that we select salon which is
money to do this this research was
because languages money is one of the
couple of well species that don't have
these kind of issues for example the
solar noon Pinelli produced some compost
that are talks before for consuming but
in the case of salami cheese money
actually is a really sweet fruit it's a
small it's a grapefruit but it's one of
the ones that have a highest bricks
bricks level and no it's not toxic you
so it's that's why we select this plant
to besides the salinity tolerance yeah I
don't know if that answers your entire
question yeah that's good thanks thank
you Anna what about you can you ask your
question yeah thank you for the talk so
I was wondering if you could repeat how
many domestication genes you know that
you have to transfer in the white type
tomato plant and if you can kind of
speed up this domestication process yeah
of course we are well these are the two
approaches that we are using to promote
or to develop the single mutant plant we
are using a genes but in the case for
the multiplex knockout we are using
these five genes but we affect these
different phenotypes so yeah beef SiC be
that it will be increased will increase
the dike open content of the fruit and
this other architect architectural plant
phenotypes what was your second question
sorry I was mainly um you know if these
are all the important genes or if you
know that there's like a black box
that's still missing
of domestication genes oh yeah of course
there are another ones but for example
there was a paper published on racing
years ago they knock out or decree that
also in functional in 16th that actually
they use some of the similar genes that
I'm selecting here but of course there
are more like can be improve in a you
know research for a research purposes we
so like this because we only want to
create it a Compaq architecture plant
and of course it could be another's that
could be also involved in these ones but
according to the literature research as
we made we decided it will be the best
ones to start thank you thank you
and it looks like we have one last
question from Hussein Azimi
the same hello hello I wondered that you
know in Turkey we have a very problem
with bio safety regulation if we use
CRISPR cast so will it be transgenic or
not well of course I will depend of the
regulation and well the relation that we
are working with right but in the case
of the United States is this that is
that is using a process based regulation
ground we can say that in the case if we
are using CRISPR cos night you'll only
make some tweaks on the genome of the
crop it will be considerate transgenic
in the case of the United States because
the well it is a process that is not a
cover by the by the well there is not
considered a genome modify crop due to
that because it is affecting only the
priests will use it only on the process
not on the production on the final
product okay thank you thank you I'm
trying to see if there another question
oh yeah here it is okay I think those
are all right there's one last question
from Julia and Lennis it looks like and
we have just about well just about a few
minutes okay do you have any idea how
many genes are involved in South Orion
simchas money oh well we know that at
least not this particular Lynch is money
but we know that there's a really
complex net of many genes involved and
at least till now but were found in
different plants and Boxey implants in
the case of she's money according to
this paper by pills in 2017 she shows
the summations and she proposed some
genes but of course most of them are not
know or will differ until now we hope
that we can find some issues or some
more insights into this matter but for
now the specific genes are and the
entire net of genes is not well identify
or describe wonderful Thank You
Stephanie
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu